le matin avant l'ouverture on va en fait
mais ce qu'on appelle le ménage on va
dans toutes les petites parcelles on
ratisse on balaye on désherbe ont taillé
les on effleure les fleurs fanées
on taille ce qui est ce qui est sexe
qu'il n'est pas très esthétique et après
quand on a fini notre nettoyage de
toutes les parcelles on s'attaque aux
allées et au massif autour dans le
festival
pour quelle finalité pour que ce soit
toujours beau toujours magnifique qui a
toujours très esthétique à l'oeil et
pour que les gens aient plaisir à venir
ici ce sont les petites mains les
obscurs les besogneux
ils viennent aux aurores et travaille
d'arrache-pied jusqu'à l'ouverture des
jardins au public des hommes et des
femmes de l'ombre dont le travail donne
tout son éclat au jardin on est quatorze
jardinier permanent et six à huit
jardiniers saisonniers sous la direction
d'un d'un jardinier en chef le matin
jardinier quand il rentre dans un jardin
il faut qu'il ait le regard en se disant
qu est ce qui me gêne dans ce tableau
qu'est-ce que je dois enlever pour pour
que ça soit le plus beau possible donc
il faut qu'il ait le regard un peu
critique sur sur ce que le tableau peut
donner dès le matin et qu'il le rende le
plus agréable possible pour que la
première personne qui rentre dans le
jardin la face waouh ils se disent je
suis le premier à rentrer ici
dans les allées et dans les bosquets
c'est une véritable explosion de fleurs
de couleurs et de parfums
les jardins se pare de tous leurs atours
et offrant regard des visiteurs
un bouquet d'émerveillement un
étourdissement de sensations
c'est incroyable c'est magnifique
le magnifique
plein d'idées pour chez moi quand je
viens ici je trouve que c'est vraiment
écoeurant que les gens de chaumont sur
loire se rendent pas compte de leur
chance quand je vois tout cette
prolifération de couleurs de parfums et
de beauté en fait voilà pour jouer ces
partitions et rendre possible cette
alchimie le jardinier se fait paysagiste
j'ai fait une petite sélection de
vivaces rapide assez simple on va
retrouver de l'agora qui va ferrer en
étaient blancs des skieuses lac est déjà
en fleurs qui va amener la couleur tout
de suite
ici on la remet ria dit gazon d'espagne
qui est en pleine de plate forme en ce
moment là on est sur du bleu blanc rose
les jardiniers n'ont qu'une pense
entretenir avec un soin jaloux les 36
créations paysagères plus de quatre cent
mille visiteurs sont attendus cette
année